great to see you I'm glad to be here
thank you and welcome to Valparaiso
Indiana
you
here here in Valparaiso Indiana the home
of Orville Redenbacher popcorn and what
would movies be without popcorns
influence on them we're here with John
Costas the mayor of Valparaiso is this
the highlight of your mayor show I've
been married 10 years we've had lots of
highlights we are really happy to have
you guys here movies popcorn stuff goes
together what's your favorite movies
recently I'm spider-man do you want to
be spider-man when you grow up yeah are
you yeah to Oscar statuettes right here
for best couple and family of the year
they could meet Oscar can meet Oscar it
I've heard the talk around town for the
short time we've been here I heard that
you guys are the best couple and family
of the year in most people's opinion oh
thank you awesome yeah yeah it's a
wonderful night for us to us trust will
win that was pretty great mal phrasal
your town we brought a little bit of
Oscar magic using the town's change well
I've absolutely orville has been smiling
a little but if you have noticed that
the lips are coming up but that he
points out to people it's a statue and
we've all fallen for it valparaiso
ready bugger Oscar he'll cheer it
whatever I say what
what everybody's doing it
it just got real weird in here